leute ich wäre euch jetzt in dem video
was sagen was mir ziemlich unangenehm
ist aber es geht einfach nicht anders
und zwar habe ich hier im kleinen pickel
daun
aber es gibt noch etwas anderes was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte wirklich sagen
wollte und zwar mit diesem neuen parker
hier gekauft
ich persönlich finde es einfach richtig
krass sowie grünes gras angesät schönen
tagen sein kann
für mich war es schon seitdem ich mich
erinnern kann unmöglich bis zum einen
fußspitzen runter zu denen okay leute
aber wo es wirklich geht
ich bin fertig mit der schule das meine
ich mir das ist vorbei kolloquiums
prüfung abiturprüfungen ende ich habe es
geschafft mein abitur ist in der tasche
und jetzt kann es richtig losgehen altes
recht neuem wir können jetzt richtig
loslegen und würde sagen
zur feier dessen zünde ich jetzt mein
zeug an
wir brauchen etwas stärkeres es wäre
nicht
leute das war das was wir heute sagen
wollte es ist vorbei
da geht die schulzeit von mir meine zeit
in meinem leben die ich persönlich
weniger gemacht habe also zumindest was
das lernen und was allerdings war immer
mega geil mit allen mitschülern und so
es ist schön diese weise tschüss zu
sagen zur schulzeit
ich wollte euch in dem video heute so
ein bisschen erzählen was du meine
erfahrung sind mit der schule und mit
dem abitur generell also ich persönlich
habe während dem abi erst mal ich
wirklich was gelernt also davor gab es
eigentlich gar nicht bei mir dass
irgendwas gelernt habe auch über die
zwei jahre also die zwei jahre die fürs
abitur relevant waren habe ich
eigentlich nichts gelernt
dementsprechend war es für mich komisch
auf youtube zu machen in der zeit weil
irgendwie war für mich eine zeit in der
ich lernen muss keine zeit in der ich
mir bewusst zeit nehmen für ein
youtube-video mich hinsetzen und das
mache weil irgendwie war es immer so ok
am handy irgendwas kurz machen ein
bisschen zocken irgendwie ein youtube
video schauen ist alles komplett anders
gewesen als sie sich bewusst hin zu
setzen und sagen okay jetzt nehme ich
mir einhalb stunden und machen youtube
video rein das ist so eine bewusste
tätigkeit irgendwie alles andere hat man
unter bewusst gemacht und deshalb kam
halt in der zeit jetzt zu wenige videos
von mir ich habe jetzt mir in extrem
coolen wie ich finde plan gemacht mit
dem ich jetzt quasi zurückkomme auf
youtube es sind unter anderem mit luca
zwei videos aufgenommen mit meinem
bruder sc kommt und auch videos die ich
ganz alleine mache werden kommen und
alle davon die ich bisher geplant haben
sind extrem nice work vergiftung
incoming ja alle videos die ich bisher
davon geplanten extrem leid und ich
freue mich wirklich sie zu machen und
noch mehr darauf sie zu teilen und zu
gucken ok dieses neue wissen
experimentelle meine verhältnisse
einfach zusehen wie es euch gefällt
ja das war es von dem video heute
entschuldigt dem kleinen klick welt aber
ich fand's relativ lustig habe mich da
so ein bisschen bei familie inspirierte
mit dem anfang fand ich ganz lustig auf
jeden fall geht es hier mit wieder los
ich freue mich wenn ihr
treu geblieben seid auch in der zeit
nichts kam und freue mich auf morgen